I mean I will be honest there are some
things that they say about Kim that no
not Kim Jong-un Kim Jong-un yeah there
are some things that are pretty wild
that guy's amazing yeah apparently he's
done apparently a lot of a really
amazing things that that uh apparently
has been propaganda in North Korea that
he's achieved all these records that
he's an amazing golfer where you told
these things when you when you were
there and one
remember from
Michael I'm not being rude I'm looking
up the things I wrote about okay yeah is
that give economy University that I mean
professors are saying how math is racist
right it's made up by white men the
Science Biology made up by white men I
thought it was Muslims I thought it was
Arabs made out of Arabic did numbers
right really yeah yeah but now they
bullying white men they think the white
men is like made up the gender I mean we
perfected it yeah we made it really good
yeah Asians are still the best at it so
I don't understand that yeah Asians are
really good at it
as a child to realize what's so teacher
asked me I mean what's one plus one
what do you say did you say two yeah and
my teacher can know my dear later
discovered if you add one drop of water
on top of another drop of water what
does it become becomes a bigger one
that's how he proved the math was made
up by the white men wow
wow that's good yeah that's good that's
kind of a good point yeah he sounds like
a wife yeah
I kind of on his side I don't know like
that adds up for me okay can I ask you
some of these things and you tell me if
these are true
um about Kim Kim Jong-un okay uh that uh
Kim Jong-il learned to walk at eight
weeks oh wow
I mean if and that's what they say but I
mean it's got a [__] I am a mother
that's that's impossible you cannot do
that you can't even crawl your kids I
know I mean you never know Kim Jong-il
played golf he shot 38 under par
including 11 holes in one do you know
what North Koreans thought
when we read that we that the holes in
one were from the sex kids scarf yeah
because we don't have God for commoners
oh you didn't know what golf was so it
made sense of course he's good at golf
and sounds like he's bragging about
stuff that people don't even know what
he's bragging about
I was like what's golf you know I
actually like that one that he's not
right he said like oh I only got 11
holes in one like he he couldn't go
everywhere yeah
invented the hamburger oh wow he called
it the double bread with meat
that guy is good with names he's like
Seinfeld like you're creative when you
name it very good very good with the
Navy and that's what they do yeah uh
yeah I mean never had the hamburger so I
don't know it's like again he's saying
that he's inventing things that you guys
don't even know what the hell it is I
have no idea what that is you're like of
course you did Buddy he would eat meat
between bread yeah right yeah you get
executed before eating beef in North
Korea now he didn't say he invented the
cricket sandwich right right
now you guys but no you didn't yeah
absolutely okay so some of these are
kind of reasonable okay okay Kim
jong-il's birth saw a new star be
created and turned winter into spring oh
wow now now what day was he born if he
was born
on the solstice that's when winter turns
into spring he was born February 16th Oh
Black History Month
it's almost his birthday Black History
Month his birthdays are the day of
shining stars here exactly there's a big
celebration so his father supported the
day of sun the day of sun is the
universe right and he gave his son who's
like Jesus Christ
the day of the shining stars
uh the great Jenna oh he's just he's
just Jesus emotion that's a big step
down you go from Jesus to General yeah
that's true because they ran out of
Bible story because the Bible in Jesus
when he was born there are stars showing
it's like Game of Thrones The Source
material ran out rainbows is like
showing us like fan fiction and stuff
plus if he was God he probably wouldn't
be so fat you know he would just make
himself skinny well it depends you guys
have fat Gods yeah the Buddhism is
extremely fat okay Kim Jong-un
um
invented comedy on YouTube and
subtitling clips what wow
internet so that we would not know
okay yeah okay okay that's good Kim
Jong-un
um played Jay Williams in an exhibition
game and one seven six
Soho
that might be the case it might be the
case
um uh Kim Jong-un uh loves Adderall
thinks it's the best drug ever for the
most fun having time I heard he loves
golniak and swiss cheese what is Swiss
cheese cognac yeah and swiss cheese yeah
13 bottles of wine ish night that's why
he's so fat
whoa yeah so cognac swiss cheese and
wine yeah and he's just getting massages
all day he's like one of those uh
panels or whatever oh yeah Kobe beef
Kobe beef yeah he's like Kobe beef so
they picked this beautiful girls to
massage the cow that he eats that's
literally one of the pleasure Squad
tasks so the girls have to be beautiful
just to massage the cow yeah
they have to hand them like to massage
your car for
eign
capability same IQ North Korea is one of
the highest IQ by nature in the world
did Kim Jong-il say that no it's a word
oh that's a word yeah okay and that's
why they built a nukes and Biden Cosmos
Korean kingdom does not call him back
whoa
[Applause]
[Music]
what country can that do that to America
seriously the Biden can call Nano call
him back yeah [__] I don't know Saudi
Arabia is the only other one yeah
but but it takes 30 seconds to make a
phone call he's got to go up a mountain
there's bad cell service
that is a really good point that you
were just making okay this is the last
one North Koreans believe Japan stole
time
from them during the 1919 occupation Kim
Jong-il
or oon
restored the time by moving it back a
half an hour in 2015.
so should I be on right it is I think
it's a more legit there's a they keep
changing history that's the thing we did
like in North Korea yeah they always say
one day this is our name what the
tomorrow is that song and I mean you
know yeah they just keep training
history but North Korea has their own
time zone they have their own calendar
they have their own race I'm not an
Asian I'm kimira song race
that's what they do I didn't know I
never seen a map of the world they don't
tell me I'm an Asian but can't you also
be Asian I don't know what Asia is they
don't show us the map we don't know what
the world looks like let me tell you
something
you're Asian
I know that perfect you know but you
could also be part of his race if he
wants it that's what he says and then
our calendar begins when kimierson was
born
um
any historical facts which is our the
world begins when he was born that's how
everything got created wow that's wild
oh because he's Christ yeah yeah
there's a Duty one that's their own
calendar that's day one unbelievable